Joseph and Frank were two life-long Squatchers.
No, that isn’t an insult – that’s a
self-given title for Bigfoot enthusiasts who
are willing to head out into the woods and
search for the legendary Sasquatch first-hand.
While most Squatchers will go their whole
lives without ever encountering one, Joseph
and Frank were about to get lucky – they
just didn’t know what kind of luck.
During a journey through the forests of the
Pacific Northwest, Frank spotted something
moving in the distance: A huge, ape-like creature
with greyish fur and human-like movements.
Frank thought he was finally laying eyes on
the mighty Bigfoot after decades of searching.
What he didn’t know was that he’d just
made a deadly mistake.
He had looked directly at SCP – 1000.
And there would be terrible consequences.
Frank was excited – he’d just achieved
the life goal of any Squatcher.
He tapped Joseph on the shoulder and directed
him to look in the direction of the creature.
Joseph followed Frank’s direction and stared
into the distance.
When his eyes finally came into focus on the
ape-like beast... he froze.
His brain just short-circuited.
One second, he was about to encounter the
Holy Grail of his hobby, and the next, he
was literally brain dead.
Joseph collapsed.
In the distance, the ape-like creature disappeared
back into the woods.
Not that Frank even noticed – he was too
busy trying to wake Joseph but it was no use.
Joseph was gone, and Frank had no idea why.
The headlines read, “BIGFOOT KILLED MY FRIEND.”
Most people either ignored it or laughed it
off.
Just a couple of cranks goofing off in a forest
and one of them had dropped dead.
Who cares?
Well, one organization cared – The SCP Foundation.
Mobile Task Force Zeta-1000, the Foundation’s
specialized SCP – 1000 detail, were alerted
to the reports.
They sprang into action, tracking down and
detaining Frank for questioning.
They process a million loony bigfoot lovers
every year, and usually find nothing, but
the death of Frank’s friend made it all
too clear – they hadn’t encountered a
bigfoot but a real, genuine example of SCP
– 1000.
SCP – 1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous SCPs, but underestimating
the creature is a terrible mistake because
just looking at it gives you a 2% chance of
dropping dead on the spot.
Frank, despite losing his friend, was one
of the lucky ones.
The Foundation debriefed him before administering
amnestics, and making sure that he’d never
venture back to those mysterious forests in
the Pacific Northwest again.
Director Jones, the site director charged
with the management of SCP – 1000 populations,
was given the information on this latest case
of a SCP – 1000-related fatality.
It was a story he’d heard many times before.
For Director Jones, they all seemed to bleed
into one another.
So, what exactly is SCP – 1000?
And how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods?
SCP – 1000 is a whole species of large,
hominid ape-like creatures.
They’re largely nocturnal, but sightings
of the creature during the day aren’t unheard
of.
They’re omnivorous, mostly seeming to consume
plants and insects and their fur is usually
grey, brown, black, red, or occasionally white.
The creatures have large eyes capable of impressive
vision nestled underneath a pronounced, Neanderthal-like
brow.
Another defining feature is the ridge of bone
on the forehead, much like that of a gorilla,
that is present in both sexes.
According to Foundation studies, the creatures
exhibit a level of intelligence on par with
that of the common chimpanzee, but nowhere
near that of us humans.
What they lack in intelligence, though, they
more than make up for in size.
The adults can be as large as ten feet tall,
and weigh up to 600 pounds.
Despite their great size and impressive strength,
the creatures are neither aggressive nor territorial.
In fact, they seem to instinctively avoid
humans, mostly residing deep in the forests
of the American Pacific Northwest and in the
Himalayan Alps.
There have been sightings of SCP – 1000
on every continent, though the Foundation
has taken pains to exterminate all SCP – 1000
populations situated near human population
centres to prevent a potential disaster, considering
the 2% chance of instantaneous death upon
visual contact.
That brings us to our second question: What
is it that makes these seemingly harmless
creatures so dangerous?
Sadly, for both these unfortunate creatures
and us humans, the danger is beyond the control
of SCP – 1000.
According to Foundation research, SCP – 1000
likely evolved alongside us homo sapiens,
until a tragedy occurred between ten and fifteen-thousand
years ago.
A mysterious extinction event eliminated the
vast majority of their species, leaving only
one to five percent alive in the aftermath.
What happened?
It’s believed that around this time, SCP
– 1000 contracted what the Foundation refers
to as an “anomalous pseudo-disease.”
Meet SCP-1000-f1, a disease that is passed
along at the genetic level, and is so durable
that it persists in the species to this day.
The tiny fraction of the population that are
immune to its effects manage to survive, but
the majority who aren’t immune die shortly
after birth.
This is why the overall population remains
relatively low to this day.
It’s a disease that only appears to affect
hominids – including humans, chimpanzees,
bonobos, and non-immune instances of SCP-1000.
Any hominid that lays eyes on a carrier of
the disease has a two percent chance of experiencing
immediate brain death.
While a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening, at least
when compared to some other nightmare inducing
SCPs, the truly scary part is that the percentage
is cumulative.
In other words, the longer one observes a
carrier of SCP-1000-f1, the higher that percentage
rises and the greater your chance of experiencing
an abrupt death.
According to Foundation studies, the percentage
rises by around one percent every twenty minutes.
And the percentage also varies between specimens,
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high death
chance of 90% upon viewing.
This death chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carried the anomalous pseudo-virus
while alive – though thankfully the risk
doesn’t appear to apply to small fur or
tissue samples.
The Foundation’s true concern actually goes
far beyond SCP – 1000 themselves.
Because of the species’ close relation to
homo sapiens, there’s a worry that SCP-1000-f1
could transmit to humans, causing our own
species to meet a similar fate.
If humans did indeed become carriers of SCP-1000-f1,
it’s extremely likely that humanity would
undergo an unprecedented extinction event,
with billions across the globe dropping dead
as brain death sets in en masse.
While full extermination of the entire species
has been deemed unlikely, the existential
threat they pose to humanity more than justifies
the occasional culling of SCP – 1000 populations.
That was a lot to take in, right?
First, the creature we thought was Bigfoot
was actually a new species of SCP out in the
wild.
And second, these creatures could end human
life as we know it if they made it into a
population center.
But what you’re about to hear next – a
dark secret only available to people with
Level 3 SCP Foundation clearance – is the
most shocking SCP - 1000 fact of all...
Are you ready?
The true secret of SCP - 1000 is that what
you’ve just heard is a lie.
There is no anomalous pseudo-disease, and
SCP – 1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever.
Who would spread such a thing?
The SCP Foundation, of course.
Strictly speaking, the Foundation has disseminated
two direct lies about the nature of SCP – 1000.
The first is that of the disease, which does
not exist, nor has it ever existed.
The second lie is about the creature’s intelligence
level – they’re far smarter than the average
chimp.
In fact, they’re every bit as intelligent
as human beings.
These were all lies formulated by Director
Jones and the Foundation, as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth.
The Foundation has been spreading information
that makes the very concept of the Sasquatch
out to be a joke for decades, all to discredit
and further push the very concept of SCP – 1000
into the shadows.
But…why?
The Foundation is no stranger to coming up
with cover stories, but why would they put
intentional lies into their own files to anyone
below a Level 3 clearance?
Well, that all comes down to the horrifying
truth behind the origins of today’s SCP
– 1000 population.
The creatures were first brought to the attention
of the Foundation by outcast members of the
Serpent’s Hand, an organization dedicated
to defying the Foundation’s activities.
These members, known as the Children of the
Sun, told them the secret history of SCP – 1000.
While at first, Foundation personnel like
Director Jones didn’t want to believe what
they were hearing, they soon came to terms
with the horrifying truth.
Humans and SCP – 1000 did evolve alongside
each other, with humans occupying the day
and SCP – 1000 the night.
However, while humans were still basic hunter-gatherers,
SCP – 1000 were undergoing vast intellectual
and societal development.
They were able to create tools, weapons, agriculture,
stable settlements, domesticated animals,
and eventually even fully developed cities.
It was like nothing the world had ever seen,
and wouldn’t see for thousands of years
to come.
Their numbers swelled into the tens of billions,
as they created culture and technology hitherto
unimagined – including weapons of devastating
power.
Meanwhile, humanity was pushed to the brink
of destruction by their competitor’s rapid
and seemingly unstoppable growth.
It looked as though the human species had
lost the evolutionary arms race, and would
have to bow out, but according to the Children
of the Sun, a trickster forest god smiled
upon humanity, and gave them the power to
use SCP – 1000’s weapons and technology
against them.
70% of SCP – 1000’s population were wiped
out in a single horrific day, known to the
Children of the Sun as “The Day of the Flowers”
– as every flower supposedly bloomed that
day during the massacre.
Humanity destroyed the entire civilization,
and with the same technology they stole from
these unfortunate creatures, the vengeful
humans drove the apes mad.
Their higher consciousnesses were blocked
out, reducing them back into the states of
mere animals.
Once the massacre was done and everything
that was built had been destroyed, we – the
human race – used the SCP – 1000 weapons
to wipe any memory of the atrocity from our
own minds.
The advanced civilization of SCP – 1000
had been wiped from history.
Humans returned to their plodding path of
evolution, none the wiser.
For thousands of years, all the way up until
today, this time remained a mystery to us.
So again, why did the Foundation lie to us?
What did they have to gain, by convincing
us all that it was dangerous to even look
at these creatures?
Well, as the frequency of sightings and the
attempts at communication increased, people
like Director Jones became aware of a frightening
possibility: What if the pendulum was swinging
back?
What if the apes were regaining their lost
intelligence, and worse, still harboured feelings
of revenge for what we did to their species
thousands of years ago?
Even the mere possibility that they could
do to us what we once did to them is a chance
that the Foundation simply cannot take, and
thus, limiting contact between humans and
SCP - 1000 at all costs is an absolute must.
However, in spite of the Foundation’s fears,
one intercepted message from the apes suggests
that their paranoia may be misplaced.
This message, translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation personnel, reads
simply as follows:
“we forgive you;
given choice for now, not forever;
let us back in.”
It’s enough to make you wonder what species
the Foundation should really be keeping tabs
on here.
After all, when it comes to meting out violence
and death, humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the Foundation
containment cells.
And few examples illustrate that better than
the tragic case of SCP – 1000.